[SPEAKER_03]: Third of Wealsun early in the morning as they take the place.
[SPEAKER_03]: After the battle, the party is taking the place and they're in the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I already moved in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Baudron pointed, just in case... At Farrowind?
[SPEAKER_02]: At Farrowind.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, now he's tied up, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: So when he looks at you, he's like... Pat kind of looking at you.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: And he looks up at you and goes...
[SPEAKER_00]: Eyes on me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just up as a precaution.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not that I want to attack, but...
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_05]: What are you guys gonna say?
[SPEAKER_05]: Is that everybody's?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, that's everybody.
[SPEAKER_04]: I am totally focused on this soul motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm like still like, you know.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's stairs that go out.
[SPEAKER_05]: I got my wallet pointed at his ear.
[SPEAKER_05]: I turn to Merrick.
[SPEAKER_05]: And, uh, so you haven't been in here, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: We need to know how we can lock this down.
[SPEAKER_05]: We don't want anyone else coming in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so, hold on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's two things we can do from here.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can try to get out of here and leave with them, which I don't think we should do.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's too risky, carrying two prisoners.
[SPEAKER_05]: You've got a whole thing of people out there that, am I a prisoner?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shut up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, the second...
[SPEAKER_00]: The other option is to go to the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that Paul Ribeiro?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, you are below my station, young man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind, you are under arrest by Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am hereby representative of him.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have committed treason.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merrick, I know you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you going to allow this to happen?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, yeah, your words can't be trusted right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm under orders of Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Jamis, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Jamis, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Jamis and their suspicion of treason.
[SPEAKER_02]: Suspicion of treason?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see that I'm under duress here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I demand that you cooperate and we get back to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are your men?
[SPEAKER_03]: They've been taken prisoner.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're in the lower... Nah, you're full of it, you're full of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can find them yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're just gonna waste time trying to argue right now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fairwind, just keep your mouth shut.
[SPEAKER_03]: They told me you've gotten too big for your britches, boy.
[SPEAKER_03]: You'll...
[SPEAKER_03]: You'll regret this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I'll regret it.
[SPEAKER_04]: No threats.
[SPEAKER_04]: No threats right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: He doesn't know me.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have some Toli trash right here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the other thing we can do is we can get to the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to hop down and keep my eyes down the hallway.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Basically they're walls.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is like an interplace with walls, but they're closed off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so I'm just gonna walk around and make sure there's nobody there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Why has the spell that has prevented the sahaugin been broken?
[SPEAKER_04]: I yell that out loud.
[SPEAKER_04]: You say that?
[SPEAKER_04]: While I got my wand pointed at the Suli guy's ear.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sharpie.
[SPEAKER_05]: Does this go all the way around?
[SPEAKER_05]: Does this meet this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like an enclosed cavern and you just walk around it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Doors, windows, anything like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Speak quickly, Lord Fairway.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a state secret.
[SPEAKER_03]: I cannot tell you.
[SPEAKER_04]: The sahaugin must be repelled.
[SPEAKER_04]: They have already damaged and killed a formal ship of Marines sent here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would defend your honor only if we can repel the sahaugin and reclaim the island.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know what caused the enchantment to go away, but it can be reinstated.
[SPEAKER_06]: How?
[SPEAKER_06]: In the caverns.
[SPEAKER_03]: Below.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you take the stairs over there, they go to the caverns, there are barrels down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: They contain a power.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is of sensitive information.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't care.
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't care about it either.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't care about sensitive information.
[SPEAKER_04]: The powder is being packed on the ships.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those are the barrels that he's talking about.
[SPEAKER_04]: Continue to speak about this, please.
[SPEAKER_03]: Paul is right.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is sensitive information.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm glad you've come to your senses, young men.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, I believe that the Toli are stealing...
[SPEAKER_00]: The sahaugin can be repelled.
[SPEAKER_04]: Only if we re-institute the barrier.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you keeping shit from us?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: As we serve Lord Jameson, Prince GM?
[SPEAKER_04]: You are.
[SPEAKER_04]: Continue, please, Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_04]: It will speak best in your case, should there be a trial.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Sahaugin are not of concern as of right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: As I said, they can be repelled.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they will.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not if the things that have been stored underneath are being packed away.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're obviously not listening.
[SPEAKER_05]: Got any more of those fireballs?
[SPEAKER_01]: That ship would go up.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_03]: Paul, they need to be told.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then they'll suffer.
[SPEAKER_03]: Below, in the caverns,
[SPEAKER_03]: There are barrels of a material, a powder, that is poisonous to the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a chemical reaction.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not a spell.
[SPEAKER_03]: Something that you keep and see in the water around the island?
[SPEAKER_03]: This is how the sea principalities have repelled the sahaugin for over 150 years.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's only a limited supply.
[SPEAKER_03]: The spell is a state secret that we use so people do not know of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, they totally have figured out our secret.
[SPEAKER_03]: They are taking our supply of it right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: So the Toli, do they have problems with the sahaugin?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have no idea what the motivations of the Toli are.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've long suspected the Toli to be involved with any parts of the blockade of Monmurg and the Sea Principalities.
[SPEAKER_05]: Also, it's one of those ships coming across the sea, if they're taking all that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Fairwind's case can be argued out amongst the Princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is beyond us.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is within our grasp right here now is to deal with the sahaugin and the reclamation of this island.
[SPEAKER_01]: We must secure this island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where are the hobgoblins from?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's controlling them?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let's take the dead one and show his head to them and I'll flame as many or fireball as many as I have.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is he dead or is he just passed out?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah, I think you burned him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, alright.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, he is gonna... Do you have anything on him?
[SPEAKER_03]: We can do that later.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, maybe I wouldn't tell... No, I wouldn't tell them anything that I took from this guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, he's talking about the one that's knocked out.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's got a very nice ripier and a very nice dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, you're talking about that guy?
[SPEAKER_04]: I thought I burned him again.
[SPEAKER_03]: But his ripier didn't burn him.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll do the loot later.
[SPEAKER_00]: All that matters is to protect Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: And to do that we have to reclaim the Hound.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I think we should do is I think we should go to the sanctuary tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: I like the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: The tower can be seen from Monmurg and they will send troops immediately.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we'll warn them of the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any way to reinstitute the protections of the island so that we don't end up fighting the sahaugin in the bay and losing valuable troops?
[SPEAKER_03]: One barrel will keep this saw again away for 10 miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then let's move quickly to secure the barrels below.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we have to take him and the prisoner with us, I suggest that's what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you blow that ship?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because that ship's going to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: That ship's still up there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was going to say, this chemical is highly reactive to fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fire?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, then I can definitely destroy the ship, but it would destroy the barrel.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think what we need to do before I destroy the ship...
[SPEAKER_01]: But that would salt the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, salt the water, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but it might, but it might also entirely destroy it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go quickly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Farrowin can guide us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Farrowin, forgive us.
[SPEAKER_01]: We still have to leave you tied up.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can argue your case in front of the princes.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we can secure at least that there's some barrels left, then we can re-secure the island, I'll blow up the ship.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's get it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we have to move quickly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we're wasting time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are we gonna go out the same way that we came in?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, we have to go down the stairs.
[SPEAKER_04]: Lord Fairwind knows whatever's the quickest route to the lower caverns.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is true, yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: What if him?
[SPEAKER_01]: The guy that I got the wand in his ear?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm taking his ass with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not leaving our sight.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can drag him along.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd like to have him put to the question formally.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can he control any hobgoblins that's gonna come our way?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sure he can, but I've got him ball-gagged, I've got him hand-tied with like, you know, super stupid mittens on or whatever the hell.
[SPEAKER_03]: His shirt.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just fluff your shirt.
[SPEAKER_03]: Any rings.
[SPEAKER_01]: I take rings off of his ass.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only thing that he doesn't have on him that I can't take is I'm not going to skin him with tattoos.
[SPEAKER_03]: The only thing he has on him, he has fine alabaster skin, not marred by tattoos.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because the Sulu don't tattoo themselves.
[SPEAKER_03]: Any jewelry is off.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has no jewelry.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, besides his clothing, he does have a very fine root here and a dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: Both of those?
[SPEAKER_04]: Toss a daybreak here to the bard, and I keep the dagger, stick it in my own waistband.
[SPEAKER_04]: No anklets, no bracelets, no nose rings, ear rings, eye piercings.
[SPEAKER_04]: We got it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cup checkums, no scrotum.
[SPEAKER_04]: Turning conf.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to double check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and then, like I said... Rolling sight.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so I'm going to take lead and start to head down the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there anything in this room?
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything under the table?
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything?
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a book on the table.
[SPEAKER_04]: We can't spend too much time.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just take the book.
[SPEAKER_04]: We don't have time to scrutinize it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Lord Fairman, how do we get to the lower catacombs?
[SPEAKER_04]: Where are the powers stored?
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to intercept them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Take the stairs.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's coming with us.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're taking more of a fair one, we're taking the prisoner.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're keeping his hands tied?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, keep him tied.
[SPEAKER_04]: I asked him for forgiveness and said he can be judged by the other princes.
[SPEAKER_04]: For right now, this will be the best case scenario.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because here's the problem, guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's say we get the hobgoblins to stop.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to have 150 of Laura Fairwinds dudes coming in here that are not going to be cool with us traipsing his ass around handcuffed and tied.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let's get what we need to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can always apologize later.
[SPEAKER_04]: He can either be proven false or true.
[SPEAKER_04]: So before his guys come into the keep and re-secure shit,
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he might even need to be in a skiff and a rowboat heading back to Monmurg with his ass by the time his guys come into here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let's move.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're gonna get that powder in the water first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, speaking of Tim, Mike Monculi is seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwinds interact with, or did I hear them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you saw them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've got a dead to rights.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no doubt in your mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was like, am I just dumb?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: You saw them.
[SPEAKER_03]: You definitely know what the deal is.
[SPEAKER_04]: But the problem is I still don't know if I can interpret what you saw.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like, for me right now as Jude, I'm like, I didn't see it, I didn't hear it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nobody else does know that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I get that.
[SPEAKER_05]: But nobody else's work really matters.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is between me and him and Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: But let's get the island reconstructed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even if the princes have something over him in the future because they all suspect and trust you, it doesn't matter because we need to get the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want us to hog it out of these waters.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'd like to get off the island at some point too.
[SPEAKER_05]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_05]: Both of these need to be returned to Jamis.
[SPEAKER_05]: Both of these prisoners need to get the water
[SPEAKER_05]: The problem is the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_05]: Get the powder.
[SPEAKER_04]: Go back, go to the tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: As we're moving downstairs, where does the powder come from and where is it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys begin to walk towards this fairway.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm in front.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're in front, and who has... Yeah, who has Lord Farrowin?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because I've got the Suli dude, and I've got Lord Farrowin.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can I carry him on my shoulder?
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, Lord Farrowin?
[SPEAKER_05]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's pretty big.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's pretty big?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Aren't you injured?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'm like... Can you walk with him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, can I walk with him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I'm like... Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's got a decent strength.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, well, he's happy with him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I will stay behind him with your hand on his shoulder.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys begin walking to the stairs.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm dealing with the mage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Paul in front with Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you going in front?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And...
[SPEAKER_03]: You're behind him with Fairwind, Gouge has his hand on his shoulder, Merrick, he's coming with the rear, and then Jude, you've got the Suel guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm assuming we're dropping our hobgoblin disguise.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, my helmet's off, mine's off, I have my mask.
[SPEAKER_05]: Not me, I look better.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna cast Curelight Windsor myself.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can lay hands, you know, and not use the belt a lot.
[SPEAKER_04]: You attribute how many?
[SPEAKER_05]: I can do up to 15 lay on hands?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you're level.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or you could do five.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a total pull.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's five per level.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so you could say, I want to do ten on myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I get my bolt out of him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so I've got a question.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is approaching 12 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm way past due for me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, because there will be another combat which will take...
[SPEAKER_03]: I was going to say, we've got to do this next time.
[SPEAKER_03]: An hour.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can we stop here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I've got to get up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we take an airplane?